[Music]
the earth is wounded and humans are
largely responsible for the pain with
our rapid scientific advancement however
we're coming up with solutions to heal
our alien planet for even thinking about
colonizing outside of our home
atmosphere make sure you stick around
till the end to learn how space
colonization could result in a new
species of humans if this is your first
time visiting our channel make sure to
give this video a big thumbs up and
subscribe today we are showing you what
would happen if humans lived in space
terraforming Mars or the moon when you
think of humans making colonies in space
your first thought is probably that we
can develop habitats on the Moon or Mars
this is something that scientists and
entrepreneurs are talking about today
with such frequency that it seems
possible in the future
the act of colonizing a foreign
celestial bodies such as the Moon or
Mars would require that we terraform the
surface of the planet terraforming is
the act of changing the physical
properties of a planet such as modify in
the atmosphere and temperature so that
the planet can be earth-like and thus
habitable Mars is the most ideal
candidate for terraforming because it
already meets all the criteria that are
needed for life as we know it to exist
there is water possibly frozen at the
polar ice caps carbon and oxygen in the
form of carbon dioxide and nitrogen
additionally Mars is the second closest
planet to our earth while Venus is
closer and potentially easier to access
she is also a fiery storm of carbon
dioxide high wind speeds and pockets of
sulfuric acid in the form of clouds
venus is far too violent and hot the
hottest planet in the solar system to be
habitable or considered for terraforming
the moon doesn't meet the necessary
criteria such as having the crucial
elements like carbon oxygen and nitrogen
so while it's closer than Mars it could
be more challenging and more expensive
to terraform warming the planet so out
of the candidates we've chosen our
planet Mars with a rotation rate and
axial tilt extremely close to those of
the earth this planet would be our best
option additionally the strength of
gravity on Mars is only 1/3 of that on
Earth and Mars is still close enough to
the Sun to
variant seasons perfect so what's the
next step in terraforming the Red Planet
the first phase and at least
time-consuming would be to warm the
planet comfortable with earth-like
temperatures currently Mars is average
temperature is negative 60 degrees
Celsius or negative 76 degrees
Fahrenheit we would want to bring it up
so that the average temperature would be
close to Earth's average temperature
which is 15 degrees Celsius or 59
degrees Fahrenheit modern Mars has a
similar atmospheric makeup to early
Earth which is pretty good news for us
if early Earth's carbon dioxide rich
atmosphere could be transformed into
breathable air we could do the same to
Mars the Red Planet currently has an
atmosphere of 95 point 3 percent co2 if
we could repeat the process that
happened on earth many eons ago we would
thicken the atmosphere and create a
greenhouse effect which would result in
the warming of the planets and more
habitable temperatures this warming
period would be relatively easy and the
whole process could take around 100
years the oxygenation phase great it's
only been 100 years and now we have a
planet with a similar atmospheric
thickness and average surface
temperature to those of Earth next we
need breathable air so humans and other
earthly creatures can survive
unfortunately this is an immense task
that could take thousands of millennia
that doesn't mean scientists have given
up though they are constantly proposing
new ideas and technologies that could
potentially speed up the process for
example scientists have developed what
is essentially an oxygen Factory that
can be used on Mars
it's a machine powered by solar energy
that extracts pure oxygen from carbon
dioxide that is abundantly present in
Mars thin atmosphere currently a
prototype it's called Mars Institute
propellant production precursor and it's
significant because it could only
potentially be used to fuel a return
flight from the Red Planet to Terra
Firma by mixing oxygen with rocket fuel
another solution that is ideologically
simpler but in practice a bit more
complex is to just introduce plants to
Martian soil plants are
photosynthesizers meaning they take
sunlight convert it to energy for their
use and produce oxygen as a byproduct
simple enough
except that planets as we
amid warmth and hospitable soil we would
need to bring bacteria that produces
ammonia as a by-product to the Martian
soil so that they could take nitrogen
from the atmosphere to accommodate large
plants like grasses and mosses a process
that could take hundreds of years
providing protection from solar wind
now that we've warmed the red planet and
made its air breathable we can start
sending humans there right not quite our
home planet Earth has this incredible
region of space surrounding it in which
the dominant magnetic field is actually
that of Earth rather than that of
interplanetary space we call it the
magnetosphere and this region acts like
a shield from solar winds that send
charged particles and deadly radiation
our way current science suggests that
Mars used to have a magnetic field much
like our own protecting its atmosphere
and giving the plan of a chance to be
warm wet and hospitable
but it disappeared 4.2 billion years ago
the Martian atmosphere was then totally
exposed to solar wind and essentially
blew away leaving behind a frail thin
layer that left the planet cold and
inhabitable to combat this issue nASA
has actually proposed sending a magnetic
field to Mars that could protect its
atmosphere and give the planet a chance
of flourishing again or at least
facilitate manned missions to the
Martian surface
many magnetospheres might be the
solution the shield could be placed at
l1 one of the five gravitationally
stable points relative to Mars and the
Sun in orbital mechanics it would stay
in position and provide a tale of
protection for Mars
to avoid being buffeted by solar winds
muscular atrophy amazing we've completed
terraformed Mars and turned it into a
planet suitable for humans and other
earthly life to settle on so what
exactly are the consequences of living
on a different celestial body the
severity of the effects would differ
between Mars the moon or even space
colonies orbiting or surrounding the
planet let's talk about what happens to
astronauts living on the International
Space Station these scientists are not
exactly in zero-g
like they would be in space because the
ISS is in low-earth orbit it orbits the
planet at just the right rate such that
the astronauts aboard are in a
constant state of free fall which Albert
Einstein posited is indistinguishable
from a zero-g environment otherwise
known to be an environment not affected
by acceleration due to gravity this is
known as the equivalent principle in the
theory of general relativity this has
serious consequences on the human body
since our bodies evolved on a planet
whose gravity was putting a constant
stress on them in zero-g environments or
environments with a smaller acceleration
due to gravity like the Moon or Mars our
muscles don't have to work as hard
thus they begin to atrophy or waste away
our heart shrinks and our neck and calf
muscles are especially effective if we
lived in a lower gravity environment our
bodies would radically change and adapt
to the new challenges of our new home
the best adapted traits would survive
and be passed on to our offspring bone
density would decrease in addition to
muscular atrophy lower or zero-g
environments would also affect your
bones this is because they're not
experienced in the same weight or loads
on them every day like they would under
Earth's gravity thus the bone tissue is
absorbed into the bone but it's not
rebuilt resulting in weaker bones that
are less dense more frail and easier to
fracture another issue with bone tissue
being absorbed in space is that it
confined itself in the kidneys building
up there and leading to kidney stones
NASA researched the effects of zero-g on
the skeleton and they found that bone
density drops at a rate of about one
percent per month this is an extremely
high rate for healthy adults for
comparison the average rate of bone
density decrease in elderly people is 1%
to 1.5 percent per year the moon has a
gravitational pull that is only about 16
point 6 percent that of Earth's and on
Mars that number is around 38 percent
these environments would be a little bit
friendlier to our muscles and bones than
living in space in zero-g but would
still have a great impact on our bodies
and potentially even our genes humanity
would need to adapt to lower gravity if
we want to live on Mars or the moon or
find a scientific solution to build a
habitat that could replicate Earth's
gravity normal blood flow would change
there is still one more consequence of
living in lower gravity environments
than Earth this one has to do with the
way our blood flows again because our
bodies evolved to tolerate the stresses
and sometimes the aid of gravity our
circulatory system has a difficult time
functioning properly in lower G
environments normally gravity assists
our circulation by pulling blood down to
our legs when gravity is absent or
significantly weaker our body's strained
to move our blood and fluids as
efficiently on earth
there's a nice equilibrium between work
done by our body and work done by
gravity in space this workload is nearly
doubled and our bodies can't keep up
consequently blood tends to pull in our
heads this effect was observed by NASA
on an astronaut named Scott Kelly who
spent 11 months aboard the ISS and was
selected due to his veteran spacefaring
experience over the duration of his stay
in space NASA observed that the fluid
moving into Kelly's head was enough to
fill a 2 liter soda bottle this is
significant because it puts more
pressure in the head and even puts more
pressure on the optic nerve this can
cause vision problems in space that
usually dissipate once back on earth but
would remain a problem if humans were to
live in space radiation exposure one of
the more serious consequences of living
in space - be it on a new celestial body
or in a space station orbiting the Earth
is exposure to several types of
radiation galactic cosmic radiation
solar radiation solar winds have changed
particles and even do magnetically bound
radiation all pose a threat to any
humans wishing to live in space
according to NASA astronauts on the
space station can be bombarded by over
10 times the radiation they would
experience on earth this paves the way
for a multitude of health problems as
radiation damages the cells in our body
long-term exposure can lead us to
develop cancers cataracts and other
degenerative tissue diseases behavioral
problems reduced cognitive function and
more in order to live in space we would
need extremely effective shielding from
all the types of radiation that would be
flying our way in order to remain safe
and healthy enough to live long and
produce viable offspring without
genetic mutations the exposure to these
types of radiation is so prominent in
space that astronauts have repeatedly
even seen bright flashes when they close
their eyes a result of cosmic radiation
hitting and stimulating the optic nerve
the same way that we can see
electromagnetic radiation in the visible
spectrum otherwise known as a visible
light also hits our optic nerves space
habitats if Mars or the moon are a
little too far of a goal for the future
of space colonization there is a third
option for Humanity
we could build space colonies in space
stations either orbiting the Earth or
completely surrounding it though the
latter would be certainly more expensive
in order to eliminate or at least reduce
the effects of zero-g on future space
colonists the orbiting habitats would be
rotated to provide a little bit of
simulated gravity thanks to Newton's
first law of motion relating to bodies
at rest or in same directional motion
and their tendency to keep the same
state unless acted upon by an external
force in this case the spinning habitat
would cause our bodies to move but the
floors of the ship would force our
bodies to move in a circular path our
bodies the one to continue in one
directional motion however which results
in being pushed against the floor spin
the habitats faster and the effect is
greater these space stations would also
need some pretty strong radiation
shielding for their inhabitants
this would probably mean no windows on
the habitat because usually the
transparent material used to make Space
Station windows doesn't act like a
powerful enough shield against all types
of radiation some habitats would be
practical in a similar manner to how the
moon would be practical and that we
wouldn't have to be so far away from
home speciation could occur exposure to
radiation bone degeneration muscular
atrophy learning to move and low gravity
environments all of these effects of
living in space could play a role in the
future of the human species loads of
sci-fi authors and directors have toyed
with the implications of a new
environment for humans on Earth as
environments change species must change
and adapt to continue to not only
survive but also to thrive this is the
concept behind evolution
what might happen if we send people to
colonize space be it on Mars the moon or
space stations all of the new
environmental factors of living off
earth and remaining isolated from
earthly humans could result in
speciation the act of a new species
forming to adapt to new habitat
conditions some humans in these colonies
might be genetically predisposed to
having a lower risk of medical
complications due to radiation exposure
for example they would need to procreate
passing on their genes and after a few
generations the colonies would wind up
with a potentially new species of human
that is resistant to radiation whether
an office would actually happen is
currently all speculation and thought
experiment we really have no idea what
would happen to isolated communities of
space colonists in terms of speciation
but given the basic principle of
evolution it seems feasible enough if
anything it's a really neat concept to
think about and makes for great movies
and TV shows would you like to live in
space don't be shy to answer in the
comment section down below we'd love to
hear what you think and that wraps it up
for what would happen if humans lived in
space if you like speculating the
consequences of hypothetical situations
make sure to check out what would happen
if all sharks went extinct thanks for
watching em see you next time
[Music]